in physics there's a sense once you get
to the theory of everything you've
understood everything
but there's a very deep sense in which
you've actually understood not very much
at all
you've understood at that particular
level how things work but you don't
understand how the abstractions on top
of abstractions form all the way to the
chemistry to the human mind and the
human societies and all those kinds of
things
so uh maybe you can speak to the theory
of everything in its history and and
comment on what the heck does that even
mean the theory of everything
well i don't think you can go back that
far with something like that maybe to
the at best to the 17th century if you
back all the way in antiquity there are
of course discussions about
the nature of the world
but
first of all
you have to
have to recognize
that the manipulative character of
physics and chemistry the probing of
let me put it this way
we assume
and have assumed for a long time
i'll come back to when in a moment that
if i take
a little device which is really
complicatedly made out of all kinds of
things
and i put a piece of some material in it
and i monkey around with it and do all
kinds of unnatural things to it things
that wouldn't happen naturally
and i find out how it behaves and
whatnot and then i try and make an
argument about how that really applies
even in the natural world without any
artificial structures and so on that's
not a belief that was widely held
by pretty much anyone until sometime
maybe in the 1500s and when it was first
held it was held by people we now call
alchemists
so alchemy was the first the early days
of the theory of everything of a dream
of a theory of everything i would put it
a little differently i think it's more
along the way a dream
that by probing nature in
artificially constructed ways we can
find out what's going on deep down there
so that was that's distinct from science
being an observing thing where you
observe nature and you study nature
you're talking about probing like
messing with nature to understand it
indeed i am and but that of course is
the very essence of experimental science
um you have to
um you have to manipulate nature
to find out things about it and then you
have to convince
others
that you haven't so manipulated it that
what you've done is to produce what
amounts to
fake artifactual behavior that doesn't
really hold
purely naturally
you